2035 c est la date limite pour vendre
des voitures thermiques neuves en europe
décision du parlement européen qui pose
une question majeure d'une mobilité tout
électrique est-elle réaliste avant d'en
débattre on pose les enjeux grâce à
samia de chiens
leur gaz d'échappement polluent l'air
que l'on respire
d'ici 2035 les voitures thermiques
seront interdites à la vente en europe
un boulevard pour le marché de
l'électrique il pourrait représenter
plus de la moitié des ventes dans le
monde d'ici 2050 des véhicules a priori
moins polluants mais leur impact
environnemental est il notre pour autant
journaliste automobile nicolas meunier
ne crois pas au mythe de la voiture
propre tout dépend d'où vient
l'électricité qui l'alimentent pour les
voitures électriques
comme ya pas d échappement ya pas des
missions locales toutes les émissions
qui sont destinés à produire l'énergie
qui se passe dans une centrale qu'elle
soit nucléaire à charbon que ce soit une
éolienne ou des panneaux solaires ça
sort complètement du spectre des mesures
ses émissions de co2 pour un
kilowattheure d'électricité elles sont
extrêmement différentes d'un pays à
l'autre
par exemple en norvège où ils ont
beaucoup donné au lien de soleil enfin
beaucoup d'énergie renouvelable le bilan
au carbone va être très bon et en chine
ou en pologne où on fait un peu
ouais c'est extrêmement majoritaire par
contre ça devient même moins intéressant
d'un point de vue environnemental de
rouler électrique par rapport à une
voiture thermique autres pollutions
cachée celle des métaux rares
nécessaires à la fabrication des
batteries comme le lithium ou le cobalt
importés de pays où ils sont extraits
dans des conditions environnementales et
humaines très contestable mais si l'on
prend en compte l'ensemble du cycle de
vie de la fabrication au dernier
kilomètre l'électrique et mais tout de
même deux à trois fois moins de gaz à
effet de serre qu'une voiture thermique
pour les associations environnementales
l'électrique reste une bonne option mais
le tout électrique n'est pas la solution
se dire que demain on pourra se déplacer
autant et de la même façon avec la même
dépendance à la voiture mais juste en
changeant à la source d'énergie c'est un
mensonge il faut aller plus loin et pour
ça il faut réduire le parc automobile et
donc pour ça il faut aller vers ce qu'on
appelle du report modal c'est à dire
prendre des voyageurs qui sont sur la
voiture qui sont aussi sur l'avion et
les a menés sur des modes de transport
moins polluants comme par exemple le
train ou les transports en commun et
aussi le vélo lorsque sa pertinence
autre défi de taille le coût des
véhicules électriques aujourd'hui la
voiture la plus vendue en france la
dacia sandero coup de 13000 euros bien
loin du prix des voitures électriques
autour de 40 mille euros pour une
autonomie confortable de la batterie
on débat autour de ce thème des
mobilités électriques tout de suite avec
mes invités maria eugenia sanaa mon jour
fraîcheur bienvenue vous êtes maîtresse
de conférences en économie à
l'université paris saclay nicolas
guilbert bonjour experts énergie chez
colombus consulting
nicolas meilhan bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes senior advisor chez eux des volumes
spécialistes du secteur des voitures
électriques et ancien conseiller
scientifique de france stratégie
matthieu croissandeau est resté à mes
côtés peut-être on peut démarrer sur
cette
décision du parlement européen mariage
et niasse a mal à la fin des voitures
thermiques 9 je le rappelle dès 2035
est-ce que c'est réaliste un peu la
question générale qui va revenir
plusieurs fois dans notre dans notre
débat en fait je pense que la meilleure
façon d'aborder cette question c'est de
dire que si on continue à faire ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est n'est pas réaliste
c'est un mirage par contre vu qu' on est
dans une situation où des toutes les
sons on doit prendre des décisions et
faire des investissements pour changer
notre mode de consommation d'énergie
il faut se donner les moyens pour
arriver à
et c'est une bonne nouvelle mais avoir
un objectif ambitieux au niveau européen
parce que d'ailleurs il faut le faire au
niveau européen ambitieux objectifs
ambitieux nicolas gaubert il faut il
faut effectivement lié cette annonce a
un objectif européen et l'objectif de la
neutralité carbone en 2050 voilà en fait
schématiquement l'objectif européen sur
le sur le climat est l'objectif français
c'est d'atteindre la neutralité carbone
en 2000 en 2050 rappelle encore comme ou
ce que ça veut dire la demande en place
à la neutralité la neutralité carbone ça
veut dire que grosso modo vous n'avez
plus
de tonnes de co2 qui sont ré rejeté dans
l'atmosphère ou alors que quand vous en
rouge terre un petit peu vous voulez
vous les compenser par ailleurs on
voulait capter et donc vous avez un
impact neutre sur sur le climat donc
schématiquement on s'est dit que 2050 on
atteint la neutralité carbone dans dans
les pays développés pour se donner une
chance à l'horizon 2100 de limiter le
réchauffement climatique à
2 degrés donc si on se dit qu'en 2050 on
est neutres en carbone c'est à dire que
le dernier véhicule thermique doit être
vendu en 2035 il aura une durée de vie
de 15 ans environ et que donc en 2005
entre on aura plus de véhicules
thermiques en circulation donc en fait
est ce qu'elle est réaliste ou pas en
fait moi je des portes la question est
ce que l' objectif de neutralité carbone
et réaliste moi j'espère qu'il est parce
qu il faut bien quand même limiter le
réchauffement climatique dont on subit
déjà des effets en europe et ailleurs et
si on veut tenir cet objectif de
limitation du réchauffement climatique
il faudrait que le dernier véhicule
thermique neufs elles soient vendues en
2035 et à nous de faire en sorte que ça
se soit réaliste alors b c'est un défi
gigantesque nicolas meilhan pour pour
l'industrie automobile ce ce tout
électrique en faire la fin de la vente
de véhicules thermiques dès 2035 même
s'il ya plusieurs constructeurs qui
annoncent qu'ils disent c'est un peu la
course à l'échalote on sera prêt dès
2030 c'est mais c'est quand même un défi
gigantesque mais en fait c'est un défi
gigantesque alors j'avais comme dire que
d'avoir cette discussion qui est une
décision qui est stupide celle du
parlement européen elle est stupide
pourquoi elle est stupide parce qu'en
fait on dit en 2035 on va vendre que des
voitures électriques mais le problème
c'est que dans six mois on a des
pénuries de carburant on a des
contraintes sur le diesel des
contraintes sur l'essence et donc la
priorité qu'on doit se donner c'est
comment est ce que j'ai écrit fit au
plus vite la flotte notamment pour les
gens qui n'ont pas accès aux transports
en commun
la voiture électrique permet de couvrir
les trajets du quotidien elle est très
adapté ses trajets là pourvu qu'on ait
une place de stationnement et une prise
n'est vraiment pas adapté et ça c'est 80
% des trajets elle n'est pas adaptée la
longue distance et donc si on était
intelligent au lieu de se dire je me
fixe un objectif de 100 % des ventes de
voitures neuves je le rappelle présente
20% des moines de voitures par an on
dirait d'ici 2030 j'ai électrifie la
mobilité du quotidien je me débrouille
pour ne pas utiliser une goutte de
pétrole pour me déplacer dans les bilans
titrage est d'accord qui font 80% des
kilomètres et donc là au lieu de faire
100 % des médecins quand je fais 80 % en
2030 20 ans plus tôt donc en fait on est
dans un schéma où on ne réfléchit que
par la technologie que par la croissance
verte alors que la vraie la vraie
réflexion c'est on part de l' usage
qu'est ce que je peux électrifié tout de
suite rapidement quelle voiture je fais
une petite voiture avec une petite
batterie qui n'utilisent pas de métaux
rares pas de cobalt panique lcd voiture
qui existe c'est la dacia sprint par
exemple qui fait 800 kg et on se met un
plan de marche pour équiper ceux qui en
ont besoin c'est à dire pas nous qui
habitons en ville c'est des gens qui
habitent en milieu rural périodes là et
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres alternatives
et qui en 2018 était dans la rue et sur
les ronds-points et pour les
constructeurs juste le défi oui en fait
ce qui risque de se passer c'est qu'on
achèterait en 2035 que des voitures
fabriquées en chine plus d'industrie
automobile et 2 c'est que aujourd'hui
seuls 20 % de la population de chez
achètent des voitures neuves 55 en
moyenne en 2035 ce sera 1 % de la
population parce qu'elles coûteront trop
cher on va écouter justement ce qu'en
dit luc chatel l'ancien ministre est
devenu président de plateforme
automobile plateforme automobile on va
dire le lobby où là c'est l'organisme
qui représente la filière auto le virage
vers l'électrique est une nécessité nous
le disons depuis quatre ans et nous
l'avons mis en oeuvre puisqu'on a
multiplié par dix en quatre ans la part
de marché des véhicules écrit toutes nos
gammes sont électrifiés aujourd'hui
l'interdiction du thermique c'est un
grand saut dans le vide et c'est un
sabordage industriel
sabordage industriel vrai qu'on
rebondisse sur ces mots mariage est né à
sanaa c'est vrai peut-être vous avez
peut-être plus précise mais il faut
moins de main d'oeuvre pour produire une
voiture électrique pour produire une
voiture thermique
non pas forcément
j'ai beaucoup lu sa tête on va essayer
de chasser des idées reçues dont elle
sait que l'entretien on entretient moins
souvent mais pas forcément pas forcément
on l'est les produits arrivent pour la
fabrication des batteries qui est
beaucoup plus robotisés bon il ya moins
de gens qu'il ya une part de vérité ce
qu'on va essayer de chasser quelques
idées reçues dans ce débat aussi dont il
tient quand même un enjeu de d'emploi
pour le secteur automobile avec cette
bascule vers le tout électrique
en fait dès que quand on sait moi je
voulais chez rester en train de
réfléchir ça que il dit c'est
effectivement
la chine a des objectifs est justement d
électrification de sa flotte et se nomme
ses objectifs sont et c'est trajet des
quotidiens dont dont il parlait donc
effectivement et les objectifs sont liés
à ces petits voitures et donc il faut
penser que la question de l'échelle elle
est importante et d'un ca marché
le fait que pour produire par exemple
pour l'entretien d'une voiture on a
besoin de moins de main d'oeuvre il faut
réfléchir à quel est le type de main
d'oeuvre dont on a besoin on a besoin
des qualifiés mais c'est là où on a tout
l'enjeu de la transition et mais ce
n'est pas forcément comme avoir moins de
besoin de travailleurs bavard besoins
des travailleurs plus qualifiés avec d
autres d autres besoins en termes de
plan de reconversion de formation etc
c'est tellement je recevais
parce qu'il faudra juste se réfléchir à
une agence ansa mais quand même elle
renault ils sont en train de mettre en
place un plan de formation de
reconversion pour des dizaines de
milliers de salariés mathieu est ce que
les constructeurs français ont été
nulles et si oui pourquoi ils ont été
aussi nul pour pas prendre le virage
plutôt électrique à la renault est un
des premiers constructeurs à avoir le
virage avec avec ça vous n'avez pas de
la taille de l'état fait pas de voiture
électrique tout à fait des voitures
hybrides serviette à 97 et ça c'est
parce qu'on avait un problème avec le
diesel d'individus japon ne te la fais
pas de l'hybride d'electric renault rno
été un des premiers par contre après ils
sont les steaks leur voiture zoé et ils
n'ont pas fait d'autres voitures donc
aujourd'hui ils sont ils sont à la
traîne mais oui mais est-ce que c'est
pas ça ce qui fait sens pour
l'association jamais
vous dit et alors on va pour la question
nature ils vous disent qu'ils y ont
jamais cru oui ou non non bien sûr que
non il y avait patrick pélata qui poussé
très fort chez renault et carlos ghosn
je me dis c'est un des premiers
constructeurs à faire une maturité en
2014 et donc donc on va venir et la
bonne nouvelle avec luca di meo c'est
que contrairement à psa stèle en tice
qui fabriquera ses voitures la 208
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas fabriqué en
france les fabricants slovaquie demain
elle sera fabriquée en espagne et là en
france on a une opportunité avec le
casino qui va faire un grand pôle
electric city on aura la r5 électrique
la r4 électrique on aura une usine de
batteries du constructeur chinois mvi
jeunes ados c est donc ce sera
probablement le plus beau projet
industriel pour norad il ya un autre
constructeur qui fait ça c'est toyota
sur des voitures hybrides à toutes les
voitures hybrides yaris qui sont vendus
dans le monde sont fabriqués à
valenciennes donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais le problème c'est que il y
aura personne d'autre que lui verte et
cela par exemple ils sont allés à berlin
on a on n'est pas capable d'attirer
d'autres constructeurs j'aurais quand
même qu'on parle aussi nos usagers et de
là est ce que c'est logique de continuer
de fabriquer ou de prévoir de fabriquer
des suv électrique qui pèse je sais pas
combien d'heures 1300 à 1400 mix marge
pour combien de temps jusqu'où ça peut
tout à deux tonnes saint-brice j'étais
bien en deçà de l'arrêter c'est une
aberration écologique on est bien
d'accord d'autant que 5 ça s'appelle une
voiture ça fait longtemps que non mais
c'est pour ça que moi je pense que cet
objectif dès 2035 il est pertinent par
contre il n'est pas suffisant c'est à
dire que effectivement si on dit on
bascule au tout électrique 2035 mais
qu'on a des suv entre une tonne et demie
et deux top 5 on va se créer d'autres
problèmes on va se créer d'autres
problèmes sur les matières sur les
matières premières sur sur les batteries
et je suis je suis pas sûr que le rythme
d'extraction sans même parler de prix
mais que le rythme d'extraction des
matières premières sera suffisant pour
suivre on va nuire aux matières
premières vraiment parce que du coup est
ce que demain tout le monde pour avoir
un véhicule électrique la réponse elle
est clairement non si les véhicules
électriques font deux tonnes 5 fait ça
si il font
700 800 kg qui font pas du zéro à 130 en
en 5 secondes et qu'on en a un usage
raisonné avec du covoiturage avec du
report modal avec des avec des
transports en commun et des pistes
cyclables dans les milieux urbains
denses pas forcément dans le milieux
ruraux s'est pas forcément pertinent l'a
peut-être qu'on pourra avoir une qualité
sonore tout lasse de la voiture dans le
social et de la place qui doit les
motiver cupidité qui doivent être posées
qu'est-ce qu'on donne comme mobilité du
quotidien suivant les suivants les
territoires qu'est-ce qu'on donne comme
mobilité longue distance pareil suivant
les territoires quand est-ce qu'on
finance sa et comment est-ce qu'on
permet un véhicule individuel pour tous
mais un véhicule raisonnable c'est à
dire pas de tonnes 5 et là l'échec de
l'europe c'est de ne jamais avoir
réglementer le poids des le poids des
véhicules
ça c'est un échec on aurait dû le faire
sur les véhicules à essence on a eu
moins de mal à le faire sur les
véhicules électriques alors on va venir
à la question d'aider des minerais c'est
notamment votre expertise qu on va
rechercher mais je voudrais terminer sur
ce premier thème avec vous sur le la
proposition au système de leasing
proposé par emmanuel macron avec une
voiture électrique à 100 euros par mois
en location etc c'est ça répond en
partie à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure ça existait déjà avant qu'il en
impose ben oui mais c'est donc aussi
bien sûr que si je dis souvent la
voiture électrique c'est la voiture des
gilets jaunes aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes gilet jaune vous faites 30 40 km 2
par jour votre facture de carburant
c'est 120 130 150 euros par mois si
aujourd'hui vous prenez une renault zoé
d'occasion en leasing s'est déjà 100
euros renault avait d'occasion ont pas
une tesla model s si vous prenez une
dacia spring 9 c'est déjà 100 euros par
mois y a pas besoin d'atteindre c'était
déjà le cas avant l'élection des
lendemains d'une aide gouvernementale
pour démocratiser l'accès à l'électrique
d'ascq c'est ça la c'est ça l'amérique
une aide et c'est ça la clé ce marché de
l'occasion il est le problème c'est que
cette dacia springs et la voiture du
futur sauf qu'elle est fabriquée en
chine donc je rappelle que la chine peu
de gens le savent c'est le deuxième
fabricant de voitures électriques
vendues en europe derrière l'allemagne
devant la france devant la france
puisque toutes les modèles tesla model 3
viennent de chine actuellement et tout
les dacia spring viennent de chine des
spring voiture la plus vendue en france
donc les constructeurs français ont pas
été très bon c'est pas une question
les constructeurs français ils ont des
règles ils sont dans un marché et leur
but c'est quand même de faire vivre leur
entreprise peugeot les courses au trot
français étaient les champions de la
petite voiture petites voitures diesel
de 105 des ailes en 2008 nicolas sarkozy
faire un cadeau angela merkel qui fait
que ça va pénaliser les petites voitures
les émissions de co2 vont dépendre du
poids de la voiture et donc plus du gros
plus tu peux émettre et donc nicolas
sarkozy a cloué l'industrie et le
dernier clou dans le cercueil des
industries françaises peugeot en 2012
est au bord de la faillite ils s'en
sortent parce qu'ils font des suv parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le choix nous avec fran
stratégie ya trois ans on propose de
mettre en place au niveau européen un
bonus malus sur le poids vous avec un
système de constructeurs vous êtes un
constructeur vous faites des voitures
plus lourdes que certains emplois vous
faites un chèque plus léger vous recevez
un chèque comme sur le co2 pour que ça
passe et ben c'est pas passé parce que
est la cible et vise avec born on
voulait pas à l'époque et nous a dit
dans l'assemblée frau stratégie fait de
bonnes études mais là ils ont
complètement pété un câble et donc et
donc c'est pas passé s'est passé il en
reste a été repris par la convention
citoyenne ils ont gardé un menu sur le
poids à partir de 1800 kg qui concerne
50 mille suv allemand on pourra dire que
c'est mieux que rien mais il ya deux
pays qui vont mettre ça en place
l'espagne a réfléchi la belgique
probable on va le mettre en place dès le
début l'année prochaine et nous on suit
alors que cette mesure elle permettait
de se passer du pétrole russe
d'accord le tout alors on va parler
d'aidé
minerai de des matières premières
effectivement nécessaire pour pour
passer à l'électrique alors on a cherché
les métaux nécessaires à la construction
de voitures électriques évidemment en
premier le lithium là on parle des
batteries aluminium cuivre cobalt
graphite mariée à johnny salah est ce
que ces métaux sont suffisamment
abondantes va dire ça comme ça pour
supporter le poids le passage au tout
électrique qui est promis la part par
les décisions notamment européennes mais
c est une très bonne question en fait et
les différents métaux ont des différends
difficulté donc les lithium c'est un
métaux abondant mais qui se trouve juste
en certains endroits et sans difficile
aller le chercher
les autres sont un peu c'est certains
sont des métaux rares notamment certains
on importe est donc là la russie à une
partie du marché mondial donc de
regarder entre 4 et 5% le club rival par
exemple et donc
et
donc pour certains jeux il est une
question d d'investissement donc de
capital y aller chercher c'est c c'est
par exemple les lithium
actuellement
c'est au moment où on parle il provient
du qe 2 603 donc et des six pays où je
me laissais l'australie
le chili l'argentine et la chine et tous
et tous et tous et lithium par après la
plupart en chine où 70% des batteries
sont produites
donc pour par rapport à la question d
aider le marché du travail on a
si on veut réussir ce pari il faut
construire effectivement plus de
ddd souci c'est qu'on appelle les idiots
factory legiga phare toys donc on a des
projections déjà aux mains des objectifs
en europe mais il faut faire beaucoup
plus est-ce qu'il ya nicolas meilhan et
ce qui est un risque d'épuiser certains
de ces métaux
si vous voulez quand un quand débile ou
métaux se lancer dans tout électrique si
dans
20 ans on n'a plus une question de coût
et
d'épuisement parce qu'en fait il y en a
des quantités énormes donc la question
c'est combien mais ça nous coûte d'aller
le chercher ok l'extraire et un mauvais
c'est comme le pétrole quand ils
dépassent les 150 dollars eh bien vous
commencé à détruire la demande parce que
les gens qui peuvent le moins se le
payer le procès - donc c'est exactement
pareil pareil pour les métaux la
différence c'est que quand les métaux
quand les prix augmentent
eh bien ça me permet de te d'avoir des
nouvelles ressources accessibles pour
pouvoir aller aller chercher je jouais
juste revenir sur un point sur la chine
vous avez parlé de terre de luc chatel
l'industrialisation et l'enjeu de la
nationalisation en fait l'enjeu cdc la
chine pourquoi c'est la chine pour deux
raisons 1 le marché européen automobile
et de marché le plus protectionniste
monde sans donald trump pourquoi parce
qu'on a des normes des normes sur la
sécurité le crash test que les chinois
pourtant passé et sur l'environnement
sur la dépollution des voitures et c'est
pour ça que vous avez dans paris il n'y
a pas de voitures chinoises ça n'existe
pas parce qu'elle ne passe pas ces
normes on avait une suprématie sur le
moteur thermique demain avec la voiture
électrique la norme sur la plus la
pollution elle saute les plus
politiquement sur la sécurité elle saute
parce que c'est beaucoup plus acide ou
qu'on fait sauter ces deux barrières qui
nous ont protégés de la chine depuis le
lire on peut pas en inventer d'autres si
bien sûr que l'an dernier nous on a
proposé déjà écran stratégie c'est de
dire par exemple quand vous faites un
bonus à l'achat 6000 euros pour la
batterie aujourd'hui on subventionne la
fabrication de batteries au charbon en
pologne en chine on a donné 300 millions
d'euros en 2020 cinquante mille voitures
fois 6000 euros batterie fabriquée en
chine donc on conditionne l'octroi des
aides à l'empreinte carbone de la
fabrication de la batterie d'accord dit
toujours qu'elle surfe à briquet dans un
pays où on écrit cité émerger des carbo
d'accord donc par exemple la france la
france avec le nucléaire et le
renouvelable parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
des voitures vertes avec des batteries
noir d'accord ok c'est intéressant
effectivement il ya un enjeu de
recyclage des des batteries nicolas
guilbert il ya un enjeu de filières qui
est en train de se créer c'est ça c'est
un petit peu tôt pour le dire alors que
un véhicule en 15 ans dans 15 ans de
durée de vie donc quand le marché aura
aimé aura réellement émergé il faut
compter plus 15 ans pour voir comment
est ce qu'on pourra recycler recycler
ces matériaux ou même les réemployer on
peut faire des on peut faire du réemploi
pour pour des pour des batteries
après sur la question des matériaux faut
bien voir que est ce que le recyclage
nous nous sauvera les matériaux sorte
peut-être pas aussi vite du système
qu'il ne doive y est rentré donc ça
pourra soulager le mal de mars ce qu'on
appelle le marché primaire
les ressources que vous extrayez ça
résoudra peut être pas tout j'aimerais
quand même dire que les questions qu'on
se pose aujourd'hui elles sont légitimes
il faut bien voir qu'aujourd'hui nos
véhicules avancent avec un matériau qui
est 100 % à porte etc et le pétrole donc
quand on se pose une question une
dépendance à l'autre alors daigne pas
tout à fait le message est passé de la
dépendance aux pays de l'opep à la
dépendance à la chine alors tout à fait
mais comme on va changer de dépendance
c'est peut-être le moment où il faut
s'interroger sur nos usages par contre
il faut pas les tuer dans l'oeuf un il
faut pas se dire que comme on va avoir
une autre dépendance au lithium au
cobalt c'est pas grave on va rester aux
véhicules thermiques déjà parce que
c'est complètement intenable d'un point
de vue prix comme on l'a dit aujourd'hui
mais c'est intenable d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue climatique mais par
contre avec la transition énergétique on
va déplacer on a déplacé une dépendance
fossiles à une dépense vers une
dépendance minérale ou effectivement la
transition énergétique va coûter en
minéraux lithium cobalt pour les
véhicules enfin pour la mobilité
électrique de manière générale et tout
ce qui va être cuivre et aluminium pour
l'électrification parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'électricité c'est 25% de l'énergie
qu'on consomme en france la projection
c'est de monter à la moitié donc il
faudra se demander comment des carbones
l'autre moitié de ce que l'on dit
l'électricité c'est bon on sait faire
l'autre moitié on sait pas trop comment
décarbonée il ya des pistes avec du
biométhane des biocarburants on verra si
on arrivera à atteindre 50% avec ça mais
on va faire progresser d'électrification
dans l'industrie dans la mobilité dans
le chauffage et tout ça ça va aussi
coûter du cuivre et
et l'aluminium d'où une nécessité
d'efficacité de sobriété de recyclage et
de réemploi mais attention c'est pas le
recyclage et réemploi qui va faire qu'on
va faire un cycle infini caisson béotien
combien d'électricité il va falloir
produire en plus pour alimenter toutes
ces voitures électriques alors on a une
on a une réponse là dessus ça dépend de
combien de véhicules électriques vous
mettez et ça dépend ça dépend de leur
quoi dans le scénario dont il ya rte a
étudié à étui dessin avec les futurs
énergétique à horizon 2050 donc trente
ans c'est environ 100 térawattheures
mais c'est 100 térawattheures si on
continue à faire croître le poids des
bagnoles et les experts débattent
aujourd'hui il faut s'en sert à water
c'est un gars de la production nucléaire
française quand tu le veuilles parc
nucléaire produit en font c'est plutôt
un tiers parce que le parking clair pour
des produits peu vous savez on voit
qu'un quart de centrales en place de
toute façon il va falloir plus
d'électricité si on veut décarbonés ce
que le rapport de rte dit c'est que dans
un scénario médian vous arrivez avec nos
mises et 40% d'énergie finale il vous
faut 645 térawattheures d'électricité
décarbonée on est autour de 400 500 ça
dépend des ça dépend des années
aujourd'hui donc de toute façon on aura
besoin de produire plus d'électricité
quand bien même en consommeraient moins
d'énergie et ça le parc nucléaire ne
pourra pas y répondre seul déjà parce
que il vit il va fermer il va fermer un
jour on peut en remplacer une partie on
pourra pas remplacer la totalité et
quand bien même on remplacera la
totalité on a besoin de plus
d'électricité décarbonée et ça c'est ce
qui justifie le besoin des énergies
renouvelables même en france alors il ya
une question de souveraineté a
évidemment autour de ces de ces minerais
rares qui a fait réagir les sénateurs à
ce rapport
cinq plans pour reconstruire la
souveraineté économique rapport qui
vient d'être publié c'était le 7 juillet
dernier propose juste de lire un extrait
nous demandons d'abord un inventaire en
profondeur du sous-sol et après dorée
octroyé des permis d'exploration et
d'exploitation minière sur des standards
durable bref relancer on pourrait dire
relancer les mines a en france et c'est
l'objectif bien celle là est ce que par
exemple si on parle du lithium vous avez
dit pour l'instant le lithium c'est
cédant 6 6 pays en tout cas pas en
france est ce que c'est en quatre pays
oui oui si et si site sicile différents
d'accord j'ai bien compris il y en a en
france du lithium sous nos pieds
exploitables éventuellement d'un comme
on dit c'est en fait il y a c'est ce
n'est pas un métaux rares la question
c'est combien
en mai et où est-ce que se trouve pour
aller le chercher donc est actuellement
le le site en europe le plus prometteur
en termes de lithium il est au portugal
mais l'europe c'est dans ce monde peuplé
d on a déjà beaucoup d'activités donc on
n'a pas dès son droit comme dans
certains pays notamment l'amérique
latine où
et il est en surface et des tout faits
sont essayés d'un centre désert où on
n'a pas des c'est sûr que s'il vecchio
mais sous une ville ça va être compliqué
d'aller le chercher c'est ça donc dé
toute façon elle par rapport à
l'indépendance et la sauvegarde et
souveraineté énergétique
on pourrait et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose réfléchir à diversifier nos
importations des ces différentes
méthodes notamment avec le lithium ça
serait simple c'est qu'il faudrait
absolument c'est 2 au lieu de dépendre
des la production des batteries en chine
à voir dès la production donc poussé
vers plus de giga facto lice en europe
on a des plans pour fr pour plus que
doubler ses marchés c'est
l'investissement j'ai la facture y
sommes il faut aller encore plus loin et
peut-être à ces moments là on pourrait
dépendre des der heydt la ressource en
veine des différents pays en dehors de
l'europe mais avoir au moins la
production des batteries
il ya un concept dont je voudrais qu'on
parle c'est cette idée de deux mines
urbaines nicolas meilhan est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer ce que c est ce que c'est
un peu un peu irréaliste et à l'idée
c'est quoi ces deux ccse réemploi ou ce
recyclage dont on parlait je pense que
c'est très lié tous ces phénomènes
ces concepts de cabinet de conseil de
smart city ou savait déjà pas l'air de
vous emballer la mine urbaine avis que
c'était très intelligent pendant le
quevillais smart city non la vie d'une
berne le principe c'est qu'on baissé de
recycler un peu ce qu'ont utilisé 2 une
fois que le cobalt qu'on avait pas chez
nous les chili sont au pied on va pas
leur envoyer au bangladesh dans notre
pays pour se faire démonter donc c'est
des grands mots c'est des beaux concepts
mais il n'y a pas une matière première
suffisante à récupérer ça peut
fonctionner si reparlons du recyclage de
batteries parce qu'on on connaît leur de
grandeur des études qui sont très bien
faites qui sont faites à la commission
européenne
en 2030 on sait combien ça peut
représenter entre 5 et 10% de notre
demande de cobalt pourra venir du
recyclage donc c'est très bien mais il
nous reste 95 sûr qu'il faut parler des
95% sur le cuivre c'est pareil alors le
cuivre bah c'est un métal qui sait le
métal de la transition électrique un
même transition énergétique donc c'est
vrai que c'est d'autres enjeux ça le
métal qui qui est très disponible mais
c'est d'autres enjeux ça veut dire du
culte est plus cher mais le vrai enjeu
aujourd'hui leur élan je sais c'est le
cobalt pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui 80%
du raffinage du cobalt effet en chine
donc les chiffres du cobalt est extrait
en république démocratique du congo
j'avais une hostie sur démocratique et
puis ensuite il va être dans des mines
qui appartiennent déjà au chinois
possèdent la moitié des mines sa part en
chine raffinage et puis après ils les
mettent dans leurs batteries mais si un
jean et une contraintes
d'approvisionnement vont d'abord se
servir eux et après si nous aurait si
l'important est ce qui me gêne à ce
rapport du sénat c'est que sur le
principe c'est une bonne idée de
regarder ce qu'on a sous les pieds
peut-être qu'il pourrait le faire sur le
gaz par exemple aussi ça pourrait être
une idée mais le problème c'est qu'en
fait en bois tout on peut tout
relocaliser sauf des mines donc en fait
il faut prendre toute la chaîne de
valeur
juste après la migros donc le raffinage
la fabrication des points la fabrication
des cellules l'assemblage des cellules
et des factures est ce que je sais pas
si on essaie de de tracer quelques
perspectives parce que je vous entends
grosso modo le tout électrique nous met
entre les mains des chinois c'est ce que
c'est ce que je vais retenir de ce que
vous voulez est ce qu'on peut y échapper
nicolas guilbert et déjà on peut y
échapper en repensant les usages en
arrêtant de penser qu'on va remplacer
tous les véhicules un pour un les grands
plus on va les faire grossir parce que
ça consommera beaucoup trop
d'électricité et surtout ça a posé un
problème sur sur les matières premières
donc déjà il faut penser
quels usages de mobilité ont fait après
on réfléchit technologies et après la la
dépendance à la chine elle est peut-être
pas évitable sur absolument tous c'est
ce qu'on dit c'est la souveraineté
énergétique la souveraineté
d'approvisionnement ce n'est pas
complètement l'autonomie on peut
dépendre en partie de certains d'autres
pays à condition d'avoir des 6000
supplée donc à condition d'avoir des des
fournisseurs des changes on peut faire
des
des batteries des batteries lfp pour se
passer durant partie du cobalt
pensée lithium phosphate en rose
utiliser d'autres j'utilise et d'autres
métaux voilà on peut avoir un mix de
solutions pourra éviter d'avoir une
solution monolithique qui nous fait
dépendre d'un de six sites dans le monde
mais après de toute façon il faut il
faut repenser l'usagé moi je crois pas
que demain on aura 35 millions de
véhicules électriques avec des voitures
qui ont acquis rendre aussi on aura un
éventail de mobilité on aura un éventail
de solutions dépendance à la chine qui
j'espère sera partiel en tout cas la
hausse qu'on a vu c'est que notre
dépendance sur le pétrole et sur le gaz
elle nous a tués en fera pas de déplacer
cette dépendance sur les minerais juste
un mot des prix le lithium c'est déjà en
train de flamber aujourd'hui oui oui
c'est une tendance c'est assez
intéressant parce que et en 2019 le prix
était en train dé descendre fortement
parce que au nab et et on avait prévu
qu'il était que cela allait exploser et
finalement la demande de descamps et à
prix très lentement c'est tout à fait le
contraire maintenant donc on a le prix
et sont remontés de 500% en une année et
ça va continuer les projections c'est
que la demande continue à être plus
élevé donc pour rebondir pour ce il faut
laisser un mot clé moi je dirais que
plutôt que la chine c'est la
planification on a beaucoup parlé
pendant la campagne électorale et je
pense que la planification il faut
réfléchir à leur esso réfléchira les les
la distribution modal nos déplacements
et par rapport à ça et planifier notre
transition pour arriver à nos objectifs
climatiques on va d autonomie on va
terminer sur peut-être des pistes
d'innovation nicolas meilhan chez pas en
moi j'ai lu qu'il y avait des
constructeurs qui commencé à fléchir des
panneaux solaires sur les voitures tous
sont des routes qui produisent des
routes avec des panneaux solaires qui
pourrait transmettre l'électricité aux
voitures c'est quoi c'est de la science
fiction
la véritable innovation si vous voulez
c'est de faire un véhicule léger que
vous puissiez vendre avec les gens
puissent acheter
c'est des choses qui existent mais les
champions d'europe des voitures sans
permis sauf que le problème c'est que
l'industrie automobile c'est une
industrie d'échelle donc pour pouvoir
aura des prix peu cher il faut en faire
en grand nombre en volume et donc des
petits constructeurs qui font des
supervoitures y en a plein mais ça coûte
15000 euros et dans ce qu'il faut c'est
que au niveau européen la voiture
électrique elle est bonne sous
conditions au niveau européen on doit
légiférer 1 sur le poids des voitures
arrêtées d'encourager arrêté
d'encourager le tank électrique donc
encourager le poids division 2 en cours
à de légiférer sur l'empreinte carbone
de la batterie conditionner des achats
sur l'empreinte carbone donc si cette
voiture électrique sa batterie et
petites voitures et petites voitures est
rempli on fait du covoiturage
elle ne contient pas de co balle parce
que c'est une batterie lithium fer
phosphate et qu'elle est fabriquée pas
au charbon en chine mais chez nous ça
commence à être intéressant on va faire
des gains sur le co2 aujourd'hui la
balance commerciale si la voiture on
achète des voitures on importe 80% des
voitures et du pétrole si demain on a pu
faire n'importe quelle proportion des
voitures et des batteries pas d'impact y
a pas l'impression d'emplois donc il
faut juste être un peu plus pertinents
c'est bien de vouloir développer la
voiture électrique mais il faut y mettre
des conditions pour que ce soit
intéressant et que ça ne puisse
réindustrialiser notre pays
on a un peu besoin même s'il faudra
quand même trouver une alternative au
gaz parce que c'est quand même énergie
de l'industrie et pour fabriquer des
batteries ça se passe avec du gaz un mot
de conclusion nicolas goldberg sur le
les critiques qui sont faites parfois
sur le justement le bilan carbone de la
voiture électrique sur ses conditions de
production de la batterie et c'est le
message que veut faire passer c'est que
plus haut plus on utilise longtemps
meyer et son bilan carbone quoi l'idée
ça de toute façon c'est vrai pour tout
appareil
électroménager tout appareil du
quotidien et ça vaut également pour le
véhicule le véhicule électrique qui a
effectivement à la construction une
empreinte carbone plus forte qu'un
véhicule thermique mais qui lui
n'utilise pas d'essence souvent un
combustible fossile à condition que
l'électricité soit décarbonée comme
c'est le cas en france comme j'espère
que ce sera le cas dans d'autres pays
attention quand on fait des critiques
sur les innovations sur ce qu'on arrive
il faut regarder le monde dans lequel on
est là aujourd'hui les véhicules
augmentent de poids quand bien même ce
sera des véhicules à essence ce n'est
pas ta ce n'est pas tenable à avoir de
l'essence en permanence tant de
véhicules on voit bien les limites
aujourd'hui se seront voir on verra les
limites demain avec le réchauffement
climatique donc il faut il faut aller
vers le véhicule était qui et c'est bien
qu'on envoie un signal fort par contre
il faut le faire intelligemment et je
souscris totalement assumé la location
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat jeu